>> Adam: JAZZ.
>> Stacey: GOING BEHIND THE ANC
PRACTICE.
WILLIE DONOVAN IS ONE OF
DeROZAN STILL WORKING. A
HAND ON IT AND SPRUNG IT FREE
FOR VUCEVIDIFFERENT IS PICKING
INGRAM.
>> Adam: DEROZAN! THE CONVERSATN
AYO DONSUNMU.  GRANT WILLIAMS,
SIZES HIM UP. AND NIKOLA
VUCEVIC AND LONZO BALL AND
YOU WOULD LIKE TO
DONCIC, A TOUGH DRIVE.
DOWN THE
FOR TWO!
A FOUL.
>> Stacey: OF THE
PICK-ANDan: FOUR-POINT GAME.JAS
SHOOT. EN, STOPS,
DeMAR DeROZAN,
TRIED TO LEAVE MATISSE THYBULLE
AND WHAT A PASS.
>> FEEL, GOOD
DEFENSE.
>> DEROZAN ON THE STEP,.
ANDRE IS NOTFROM.>> Jeff: NO, N,
REBOUND, FOUR RIGHT WALKING O
THEY GET OPEN ON THAT PLAY.
MIKE
>> Mike: DeMAR
WINDLER PICKS UP DeROZADeROZAN
TONIGHT'S NOT
LEAVING MY HEAD.LONG.>> Adam:
DEMAR DEROZAN FOR THE ISO.
HE'S GOT THAT  DeROZAN FOR MVP,
YOU SHOULD, YOUOF 6. WORKING
FO